Hello, good morning, everyone. Welcome
to day 4 of
Reinvent. Um,
so just a quick note, I know you guys saw the session
title about building intelligent agents.
Uh, the punch line is this is still the
same session. It's just I put the
answer like right there,
um.
So, uh, just to queue up
really quick, this session is going to be a little bit more
educational and less specific about
how to apply Mongo DB.
And voyage, uh, for building agents,
I encourage you guys to come hit me up. I'll
be outside the hall, uh, to answer any
questions and also we have a team that's at the booth
where we can do a more in-depth demo. But,
uh, for this session we felt it was really important to
honestly do a primer on agent memory
because if you're looking at improving the quality
of your agents,
um, or rag pipelines,
architecting and how you architect your agent memory
is a really good place to go.
Um, so we all
recall, uh,
this MIT report,
uh, I believe, about how 95%
of organizations are seeing zilch,
right, value,
um,
and there's been a lot of reasons posited.
I think all of us kind of feel this a little bit
that we're still not quite at the
point where we have a high conversion of
like POCs to production ready
apps, right,
um.
And this study was, you know,
it had about 300, uh, samples
that they looked at.
They spanned across all different industries,
um, and they found that it was pretty
consistent in terms of the challenges
that businesses had,
um,
but they also had a,
uh,
quote about
the 5% who were successful.
All right. Um,
now, their claim was that, and they call
this the dividing line,
was that it wasn't really model
quality, regulation or
infrastructure. Uh, it was actually the design
of these agentic workflows and systems.
Um,
something that we've all experienced, for example, is,
you know, agents losing track of user goals,
uh, they forget earlier details,
uh, provide inconsistent answers,
and repeat work.
Uh, there was a fun paper from Carnegie
Mellon called The Agent Company,
uh, something like, something like that, and,
uh, what they found was when they try
to replace like human tasks with
agents,
uh, it ended up.
Running the business to the ground,
uh, these agents would lie,
um, and they struggled with opening pop-up
windows. So, in case
anyone's wondering if your job is safe, if you can open a
pop-up window, you are like so good,
um.
You know, so, but all these failure,
failures, they're not reasoning failures necessarily.
Um,
we would argue that they are memory failures
because at the end of the day, most agents today are
kind of stateless systems pretending to be stateful.
Um,
now, there's a ton of really
interesting papers that have been published. These are a few of
my
favorite, um, there's more, but
if we take a look at this, um,
you know, when we examine long
horizon behavior, um, the data is
pretty clear. Performance degrades
significantly over multi-turn or multi-session interactions.
Um, well, all these studies would show that
anywhere between 20 to 40% accuracy drops
in long tasks,
uh, your retrieval quality decays over
time. And these agents frequently,
uh, contradict earlier inputs.
So, real-world systems, you know, are consistently
exposing the same pattern that without
engineered memory,
agent performance collapses as you add
on more interactions.
Go. Um,
two of my favorite charts
in particular,
uh, when people ask, well, why is it important
to,
you know, think about like how do you architect,
uh, engineer your context,
and so on and so forth, uh, is the,
uh, Lawson Mill paper and,
uh, context brought from Chroma.
Um, so, you know, independent research from
companies like Microsoft,
Stanford, Chroma
showed that, uh, two, there's two insights, right?
One is that elements get lost when sequences
get long.
Um
And then they,
you know, lose these like constraints and
drift from the original post, right? Uh, so this
happens even when the context window is large enough
to contain the relevant information.
Um, and the other aspect as well, it's where
that information is located,
right? Um, the position of that
information matters in terms of how likely it is
to actually be retrieved.
Um, so the problem isn't just missing tokens,
it's CLM's inability to maintain the stable
state across time, and this is why context
alone isn't memory.
Um.
Now the cost of poor memory engineering is
these systems become expensive, unreliable,
and unscalable. And we'll,
I'll dig in a little bit deeper into
why you can't just get a bigger LLM to
kind of solve this problem.
Um
And you know there is a cost, right, because
when users are using your product, whether
it's internal users or external users,
um, they eventually start kind of losing trust
like getting that experience
of your early, early POCs is really, really
important, um,
because eventually sometimes like you just don't get that second chance.
Now let's,
let's dig in a bit to.
The MIT report where they said that
uh
the issue is really once again it goes back to
most AI systems
do not retain feedback. They will not adapt to
context and uh
they generally don't improve over time, which is why you
have like
2 like $20 200 dollars consumer
apps are consistently beating out $200,000
to $80,000 enterprise implementations.
Some of these implications are even more expensive, um.
You know, so that's why we kind of wanted
to dig into this primer a little bit because,
uh, I work with a lot of our customers. Um,
some of them are more like cutting edge like
AI native startups,
uh, but a lot of them tend to be
more enterprisy, um,
customers who maybe have legacy systems.
Uh, they're not AI native,
but they would like to be AI fluent.
And they tend to kind of circle
around some of the same questions in terms of,
well, can't we just use a bigger LM?
Can't we just,
you know, um,
throw money at the problem. And it's like, no.
Eventually you have to throw engineering, good
engineering at the problem.
Um, now, let me just
sort of refresh
everyone on what are the limitations of LMs
and relying on them for everything.
Um, and this is really important because once again,
I do get questions about
like the usage of LLMs as embedding
models, things like that, and they are different.
Um, but let's talk about LLMs, right, which are
the core reasoning brain of most
agents.
Uh, so there's
limitations of LMs.
Um, so LMs are powerful reasoners,
but they are fundamentally limited when it comes to memory
and knowledge.
Uh, for example, we
all kind of know that they only store
information in their parametric memory,
i.e., their model weights, the stuff they were trained
on. Um, so they can't learn or
accumulate experience after training.
The other aspect as well is that their context
window is temporary, so anything outside that
window disappears immediately after a generation
unless you have saved it someplace, you've persisted
it. um, and critically LMs
have no notion of persistent state across turns
or recessions unless you build that.
Now,
can't you just get a bigger boat? Uh,
can we not just expand the size of
LMs?
Um, and many, many teams try to fix,
uh, the issues that they have with agents
by just getting a, an LM with a bigger
context window.
Um, but larger windows arguably
don't function as memory. You could say like, well,
I've trained more data into
the LM.
So does it not have more knowledge? Yeah, it does.
Um, but let's think back again to
the charts that we saw earlier, right? Which
is one,
the longer your context gets,
uh, you still have that positional
accuracy and retrieval problem.
Um,
and then the other thing as well is.
My favorite saying in the world, a 1 million
token context window does not equal reliable
performance at 1 million tokens.
Um, now the other thing I didn't
really mention,
uh, about the Chroma paper, uh, that
I should have
was this insight. So who wants
to guess, um.
Throw up your hands, I'm gonna toss some numbers out.
Uh, the percent of the effective
context window that you have
for, let's say a 1 million,
uh, token LLM.
Who here thinks you get to use like
80%?
Of the LM.
What about 60%?
It's not like one hand,
40%.
Yeah, OK, what about 20%?
Awesome. Split the middle. It's like someplace
in between. It's like 20 to 30%.
That's actually the effective, uh, context
like tokens that you get to use
for an LLM,
um. Because
Let's go back to this, right?
Let's think about this again, right?
Um.
That earlier chart where I showed that input
output into the context window, right? That's
kind of how we think of LMs,
uh, but what you don't see is all
the junk that gets added into the context
for tool calls, system prompt
information, all that good stuff.
Um,
now, we can solve this,
uh, historically as human beings. So
my background is actually in anthropology. I did
not study computer science. I was late to
the game, uh, but it's shocking how
many of those like concepts in anthropology,
the study of humans and how we've evolved
as a
socio cultural group of animals, uh, applies
to.
Jenner of AI,
who knew, right?
Um, so,
here's the thing, right, humans, we've always extended
our intelligence by building external
memory systems.
For example, we had oral traditional, oral
traditions in writing.
Uh, we came up with books and libraries
and archives, partially as a way
to further persist whatever information we
had, but also to share and collaborate that
information. And
then we had the internet.
Oh, what a great time. This was fun,
right? So,
these are all essentially exocor cortices that
we've built, so information can persist
beyond our short biological memory limits.
Um,
we can kind of think of civil civilization
itself as like humans,
humanity's externalized like long-term
memory. It's a a system for storing
knowledge, organizing it, transmitting
it, and letting future generations benefit
from past experiences.
Um, so once again, we figured out
the answer to how we give agents
the right knowledge at the right moment and to
preserve what they've learned over time.
Um, AI agents need the same thing.
Uh,
the LM is a reasoning engine like the human brain, but
the memory system is the exocortex that
holds durable knowledge,
experiences, and state.
Um, now one of the biggest misconceptions today
actually is treating context as memory,
and I wanna dig into more about like what,
how those are actually kind of different and also how they work
together. Right?
Um, so it's helpful to
kind of just baseline on like what a
context window is, what context is, and
what kind of goes into it.
Going back to the like the question about
the effective percent of your,
um, of a 1 million
model that you get to use,
right? Uh, so
context is the information assembled
for, uh,
an LM call, right?
Uh, it's the fixed amount of texts or tokens
that an LM can process in a single interaction.
Essentially the LLM's working memory, right? And this
is true also if it's a multi-modal like
model as well.
Um,
so it's, it's what exists for that like
moment. Um,
so agent memory, uh, this is our
definition of agent memory that is,
should be similar to what other people have said,
um, and that is agent memory is
persistent memory management systems that
transform stateless AI agents into
intelligent entities capable
of learning, adapting,
and maintaining continually cross interactions.
I apologies, guys. I've done like 3 talks
this week and booth duty. I'm like,
my voice is kinda.
Dying, um, so apologies once again.
Um, so
memory is durable. It persists across turns,
sessions, and tasks, and it can evolve as the agent
interacts with the world,
depending on how you architect it.
Um,
Now, let's talk about
the relationship between, let's introduce the
idea of the relationship between memory
engineering and context engineering, right?
Um, so they work, they do work hand in hand.
We're not saying
only build memory and neglect context
engineering.
Um, there is a process you should go through, right?
Similar to how everyone started with like
prompting and prompt engineering,
and then you start moving towards working with
context,
and then you wanna start thinking about memory
engineering, right?
Um, so retrieval builds
context, but retrieval does not create memory.
Uh, for memory, you need writing, storage,
summarization, embedding, and evolution over
time, right?
Um,
and this is all instructions, tools,
knowledge, all that gets dumped in the context window.
And wouldn't it be nice if you could,
I don't know, like curate the
information that gets pulled in.
Um, now for
developers, this means you can't rely on Yella Malone
to maintain state or accumulate experience.
You need to build these explicit memory layers.
This includes context engineering to surface relevant
information, memory engineering
to store and organize long-term state,
and of course evalves to ensure the memory
system is accurate, stable, and non-drifting.
Um, once you understand the elements and limitations,
it becomes clear that memory isn't optional. It's
the foundation for reliable long
horizon agent behavior, and I
would pause it to argue that
the more you're willing to invest in
like your context engineering and memory engineering practices,
the more freedom and autonomy you give
yourself as a developer, as a development
team. To not
constantly rely on,
for example, a Frontier lab creating the next
new model,
right? You don't have to wait on some
external entity
to improve the accuracy
and the quality of the
agents or the agenttic workflows you build. You, you
have that control in your hands. It's a wonderful,
beautiful thing,
um.
And
Yeah, and like once again like.
If there's a question about the place
of software engineering in the time of Generative
AI, um.
Like someone said, there is only, we
should look at the growth opportunities. The
growth opportunities for us as
technical professionals.
How can we apply the best practices we've accumulated
to improve these systems.
Um,
now, let me talk about
the anatomy of an agent.
Right, this might seem kind of basic,
but it is really important
because once again, I, I still get questions about, well, what's
the difference between like an LM versus an embedding
model versus like a re-ranking model.
Um,
you know,
like,
what if we get to the point where we have a
super, super
like insanely amazing large
model? Can we not just drop that
in and replace it?
So it's important actually
to go over this.
Um,
so AI agents.
Definition there, but, uh, we
can think of agents in terms of 4 faculties.
Um, the first one is cognition, which is
where the element plays a role.
Uh, the second is action, which
is provided by tools.
Uh, the third is perception, which is
like inputs essentially.
Um, and then finally, memory
in terms of short and long term.
Um, now, to be clear, an LM becomes
an agent when it's embedded in a loop where it
can observe,
think, act, and update its
understanding of the world.
So instead of just generating text, an agent performs
the structured reasoning, calls tools,
and manipulates external systems.
To a certain degree,
um, depends on how, you know, risky you want to
play and it responds to this environment.
The perception, reasoning, action,
and feedback cycle is what differentiates stag
chatbots from
adaptive interactive agents.
Um, so this is kind of
typically what an agentic,
uh, system looks like.
Um, so if we kind of follow the
flow, um, every agent request
breaks down into distinct phases.
Uh, we have the environment which sends an observation.
Usually through a human or maybe even another
agent. Um, we
have the system that builds context. We have
them all that performs reasoning.
We have tools that could be invoked, and we
have results that are written back to memory.
So understanding this anatomy,
uh, clarifies where memory reads and writes
occur and where you as a developer must
intervene,
right? Um,
but yeah, once again, like, you know,
just to
summarize, we have data, that data gets
processed, uh, you can chunk it, you
can embed it,
um, that gets dropped into
a vector database, and
information from that is retrieved.
So I've gotten questions from people going like,
oh, doesn't agents, don't agents
negate the need for rag? It's like, no, rag
could be a tool.
And you could do semantic search, you could do full text search,
um,
doesn't matter, right?
Um,
I didn't mention, I, I said this was gonna be more educational,
but, uh, just to do my duty
of pointing out
in green, uh, where Mongodibi Atlas
and Voyage lives,
um.
So, modern agents rely very
heavily on tool use, calling APIs,
databases,
code execution, search systems,
sectional services.
Um, so the reasoning loop looks like react,
right? The mall thinks, it decides,
it performs a tool action,
receives feedback, and continues reasoning.
Um, now,
where MongudiB fits, right, is
we provide an operational database,
we provide a vector store,
um, and your agent, for example, would
interact with that vector store,
uh, with embedding malls provided by
Voyage and with,
for example, uh, retrieve
documents,
um, being re-scored through
our re-ranking malls.
And we also know I'm Speer.
Um
Let me kind of continue on because I'll
drive you guys through
what memory types actually
mean. Um, now we've
talked about like, um, agents,
right? Single one.
and now we have like multi-agent systems, right?
Which are basically just collections of
agents,
which means a couple of things. Uh, the
same problems of single agent
still apply.
But then you also develop kind of new problems,
namely around coordination of these agents.
Now, we would argue that
these coordination problems could actually be solved
by.
A good shared state.
Um,
that these guys can access.
This shared data substrate, you could say,
which keeps all agents synchronized and
prevents freezing drift.
Um, now,
what,
what, for example,
does short-term memory look like?
Uh
It could look like persisting checkpoints
in Mongo DB.
So for example, we have a,
an integration with Lang graph,
um, where if you want to build
like an agent or a multi-agent system,
um,
you could essentially persist a short-term memory as
a checkpoint through the Mong DB saver.
And you know, the fun part is the way to
check that it's working is, uh, you
run the agent chain once
and then you go and you delete these checkpoints
and you ask the agent,
what did we talk about and they'll say
hello there, good man.
It, I mean, maybe not, it'll say hello, uh.
How are you?
I don't remember.
So yeah
Um, so agents need a way to take snapshots
of their state, what tools they've called, what
steps they've completed, and what their current
objectives are.
And so
essentially as each step or node in this graph
is executed, uh, new checkpoints containing
the checkpoint ID and the threat ID that belongs to
would be ran into MogdiB
or, you know, any database provider,
right? But that's essentially how these checkpoints work.
Dang,
that did not
turn out well, but
nevertheless, uh, this just goes
back to reinforces the anatomy of an agent.
Um, and also the four characteristics that
we, we kind of want, um, our
agents to,
to feel like and what users expect,
namely that agents are reflective, we've
mentioned this several times,
um, that they're interactive.
That they're reactive and proactive,
so rather than you have having to like prompt them for
every little bit,
um, they give you a little bit more,
um, and some level of autonomy,
although.
This is questionable in terms of
where you you individually
would want to like set your autonomy level,
right? There is a lot of talk about fully autonomous
agents, but, you know, in my experience, most
companies don't want that. Um,
what they want is what we call almost
like a level 2, level 3 agent,
where you have a mix of like some determinism,
um, and then in key areas, you might have
some non-determinism,
but even then it's.
Not, not, people are really not like
my experience building fully autonomous agents.
Um,
I'm so sorry you guys.
It, it too is feeling the day for reinvent
Energy.
All right, um, but understanding where,
uh,
each memory layer fits, uh,
is key to building these stable agents. And
each type of memory solves a different class of
problems.
So we'll build on this in the next act as we move
from context engineering to
full memory engineering, what that looks like.
Also, you can connect with me uh
after the session and on LinkedIn and
I will send you these slides.
And they will be very pretty.
Uh, OK, so I've, we've
described, um,
the anatomy of an agent in a multi-agent system. Uh,
we've outlined the problem
of why LMs misbehave,
um.
It's helpful to actually talk about some application patterns,
right, uh,
specifically to explain how different agent application
modes would shape the memory requirements.
So an application mode describes how an agent
interacts with this environment, its
operational rhythm.
Um, each mode drives very specific
memory requirements, uh, and no matter
what the industry is, their use cases can
be clustered into a few recurring patterns, and
we call these application modes.
Um, now these are the three.
Feel free to, uh, take a picture if you'd like.
Especially since the formatting on this is much nicer.
Um
So I'll just kind of talk through them a little bit. Um,
but the three key modes are,
um, assistant mode agents,
which typically need conversational continuity.
You have uh workflow mode agents,
which needs step by step procedural recall.
And autonomous or multi-agent systems
which need shared memory to coordinate
decisions. And
for everyone, that's, that's a deep research agent,
typically. Um,
so understanding these modes helps us design
the memory architecture that matches the agent's
operational power rather than taking a one size fits all approach.
Um, so the first one is
conversational assistant.
So in assistant mode, the agent's memory
must pres must preserve the user's preferences,
past conversations, and long-run objectives.
And this is where short-term memory, semantic
caching, and episodic recall matter
most. Um, the agent should
remember what the user cares about,
not just repeat steps or lose thread.
So this mode, uh, Hadley exercises
context engineering and continuity benchmarks
like locomo.
In workflow mode, um, the agent
executes a series of predefined
or dynamically generated steps.
Uh, so here memory isn't about
conversation, it's about procedure.
You preserve outputs,
intermediate states,
decisions, and toll results, so the graph
can continue, can continue deterministically.
Um, procedural memory and state logging
become the backbone of this pattern. Uh, so
we can think of the,
you know, like no code, low code tools,
uh, for example,
a partner of ours, NAN.
would be a pretty good example of this.
They have, uh, a workflow agent or
an agent
where you can describe kind of what you're looking for
and they'll output this workflow, right?
Um, and in deep research mode, the
system operates as a coordinated collective of
specialist agents,
each one taking on
like a research role such as, uh,
retrieval, synthesis, critique, or
cross validation.
Um, and here memory isn't conversational
or procedural as much as it is about
being collaborative.
Um, agents contribute findings, hypotheses,
citations, and evaluations into a
shared research record
that evolves over time.
The quality of the research depends entirely on the stability,
accuracy, and structure of the shared memory
layer. Which becomes
a single source of truth that agents iterate on, refine,
and challenge as the investigation deepens.
Um, now, just to be clear.
You can have all of these actually in
the same feature or in the same company
or as the same product.
Um, we're not saying that these are mutually exclusive, but
it's just that if you kind of zoom in on a part
of the process,
you can usually kind of fit it into one of these buckets.
Um
Now let's just dig in a little bit deeper into
context and journey.
So what is context engineering?
Um, it's the discipline of controlling exactly
what the LMCs at inference time.
Since the model's internal memory is limited and volatile,
we need to construct the optimal input context
for every step.
This means retrieving the right information, shaping
it, ordering it, and trimming it
so the all understands the task, the state, and
what matters right now.
So if memory in engineering is about what the agent retains
and offloads, um, context engineering
is about what the agent focuses on.
Um, now let's just talk about
retrieval,
the retrieval pipeline.
So modern context engineering starts
with retrieval.
A retrieval pipeline
transforms your raw data into context the
model can actually use.
It'll chunk docs, embed the chunks,
store them in a vector index, and retrieve the
top few candidates based on semantic similarity.
Um, this pipeline is the difference between an agent
that guesses and an agent that grounds its
responses in real information. So common
question like I get is how do we cut down
on hallucinations of LMs? And
one of the ways you can do that is you provide the LM
with enough grounded information
that it doesn't need to make up stuff on the
spot. Right?
Because that's, they're post-trained to be
helpful,
and helpful is not,
yeah, nah dude, you're on your own.
Helpful is giving some kind of answer, even if
it's not the best answer.
Um, now when we talk about
zooming in even further,
uh, chunking, indexing, and me.
So in this retrieval process, uh,
chunking and metadata
profoundly affect retrieval quality.
Two large chunks create noise,
and two small chunks lose meaning.
Metadata like
topic type, time stamp or project
lets agents filter and target the right information,
especially when data sets grow.
And this becomes really important, right, because for example,
if you're exposing a certain number of like tool
calls to an agent and there's no description
about what those tools actually do besides the name,
um,
yeah, it's not gonna do very well.
You gotta, you gotta help the agent
help you. And
this is also where retrieval precision either succeeds
or collapses.
So,
one powerful technique that the Voyage team,
um, has researched and looked into,
uh, they released a model called Voyage Context
3,
is contextualized,
uh, chunking.
Or contextualized context, um.
And instead of inventing the user's raw query,
uh,
what you could do actually, for example,
alongside with the Voyage conduct 3 model,
um, is you could rewrite the query to
reflect the intent, task, context, and domain
language,
and this process will dramatically improve
retrieval quality for long horizon tasks.
Now let me dig in a little bit deeper actually. um,
so.
What are some additional ways that you can improve
like the quality and performance
of your agent?
We've talked about the,
we dug in a little bit about the embedding and chunking
process, um, but there's something that you can
also do on the query level,
right? So one
thing you take a look at is query augmentation.
Um, and this is a process of improving a user's
raw query,
uh, before retrieval happens.
And the goal is simple, make the query better
aligned with how knowledge is stored,
so the agent retrieves richer, more relevant information.
And there are 3 major families of augmentation.
So the first one is query rewriting.
And this is where the model restates the question more explicitly,
adding missing context or clarifying
intent. The
second one is query expansion.
Um, and this is where the mall generates multiple
variants of the same question,
using synonyms, related terms, and
alternative phrasings to increase recall.
And finally, you have query decomposition,
where a complex multi-part question is broken
into smaller targeted sub-queries
that can be answered independently.
Together these techniques dramatically enhance
retrievable quality,
and they can reduce hallucinations
because you have a clear question, you get a clear
answer. And they can help
increase grounding.
Combine this with
improved retrieval and you're in a good spot
so far. Um,
Now, how do you know that
your efforts in context engineering
are working?
Um, now consequ engineering isn't guesswork.
You can measure it.
And to evaluate or to validate
that retrieval is genuinely helping them all,
we need to evaluate 3 things.
Um, the first one is how relevant their tri
context is.
The second is how well the album actually uses that
context.
And the third is whether the context supports
multi-t reasoning.
And this is where you might hear benchmarks
like context bench,
uh, rag,
uh,
rag Truth, and locomo come in. Crag is actually
more of a technique, but there are some
data sets that are used for evaluating it.
Um, so each of these data sets and benchmarks
will test a different dimension of context quality.
Um,
now, common retrieval metrics are
still very useful, actually,
in terms of evaluating,
uh, context engineering efforts.
And it's helpful to just kind of talk
about this before we get into more advanced metrics.
Um, so precision at
K, recall at K.
Precision at K measures how much of the retrieved context
is actually relevant,
and recall at K measures how much of the
important context we successfully retrieved.
So high precision reduces hallucinations
and high recall ensures the agent gets all the
necessary evidence.
And balancing the two is the foundation of good concent engineering.
Um, some people will, a lot of people
will actually use a harmonic mean
F1K as well, and it's a single metric
that attempts to capture the trade-off between these two.
Now I'd mentioned some, uh,
benchmarks and some papers and evaluation data
sets. Um, so a little bit more
information about these three.
Um, so valuing retrieval isn't just about
the embeddings alone.
You need to validate the entire retrieval pipeline.
And benchmarks help us understand whether the
embedding model encodes the right semantics.
Uh, whether our re-ranker is improving grounding
and whether the system retrieves consistent context
across multi-tenant interactions.
Now the three I've listed above,
um, just a
quick summary of each of them, uh, so context bench
measures retrieval accuracy across different
task categories.
Um,
Craig evaluates grounding and hallucination
under realistic workloads.
And locomo stresses the retrieval system over
multi-turn dialogues to test context stability
over time. So when you hear these guys mentioned,
this is what, uh,
they're used for.
But
arguably, uh, you,
when you are doing evals in terms of what is
working for you guys, you should test on
your data
because performance on benchmarks does not
always correspond to real world
performance for your production systems.
Now, getting into memory injury.
Because essentially that's what Talk of this is about. This is where I've been
driving to.
Um, so let's define
what memory engineering actually is.
Um,
now let's go back to this
one.
so memory engineering is a discipline of designing the systems
that allow these agents to accumulate experiences,
retain knowledge over time, and develop continually
cross stacks.
There's a collection of methods that churn these raw
agent interactions into structured,
retrievable, durable memory objects,
so the agent becomes smarter with use.
Memory entering is about ensuring the right information is available
later. Persistent
and clean structured forms.
Whereas context engineering is about retrieving the right
information now for the agent.
Um,
so,
let me talk you through the hierarchy of memory types
that we've been seeing.
For our users, for our customers,
and that also been talked about, um,
by various researchers.
And when we talk about memory for agents, we're not just referring
to like one thing.
There's kind of 3 types.
Um, there's short term memory, long-term memory,
and shared memory,
um.
And these are kind of like the three core layers. So short-term
memory is the agent's working space.
It's the information that's held inside the reasoning loop
for the current step or immediate sequence
of steps. It helps agents stay focused on the local
objective.
Long-term memory is durable knowledge stored
outside the model,
enabling the agent to remember facts,
decisions, experiences.
And finally, in multi-agent systems,
we also introduce shared memory.
The gold layer that every agent reads and writes
from, ensuring coordination, consistency,
and collective progress.
So these three layers
will form the backbone of most reliable
agentic architectures.
Um, now we do get a lot of questions about,
OK, well then how does, how does data and how
these interactions become memory.
Um,
so for an interaction to turn into
usable memory, it must move through a transformation
pipeline.
And the sequence looks like this. Uh,
first you have kind of raw inputs, right, which is
the queries, actions, docs, and observations.
These are transformed.
They can be summarized, they can be
extracted,
they can be embedded
and or normalized into a structure format.
They're stored.
They're persisted in the right collection or memory table.
Conversations, long-term knowledge,
personas, tool outputs,
um, and really this is kind of like
a circulating
set of stages, right?
We index it.
We make it searchable with vectors,
metadata, and keys so it can be
accessed later.
Um, and then retrieved.
We serviced it at the right moment to influence for
future reasoning.
Um, so this loop, the input, transform,
store, index, retrieve, is the moment when data
becomes memory. Um,
if you skip this life cycle, you're
not really building memory, you're just kind of like accumulating
logs.
Which are still a very crucial ingredient,
right,
for building long-term memory.
But memory engineering at the end of the day, it's intentional. Um,
you need to decide what matters, uh,
compress the rest and make everything else retrievable.
Um, now let's just talk a little bit
about the steps in a memory life cycle.
Um, so once you understand the types of memory and agent
needs, the next step is building the memory life cycle.
That operational pipeline that we talked
about,
that creates memory and ensures agents are
RBC.
Reliable, believable, capable.
Um, so if you're trying to figure out,
you know, whether you're like agent or agenttic
work flows
or agent-like system,
um, is working,
you can pull your users and just even
ask them along these lines.
You can also, for example, curate your own
eval data set,
um,
and essentially try to create
kind of measures or calculations
that can capture these things.
Um, now let's just talk about like
a little bit deeper into the stage of the life cycle.
Um, so the life cycle, like we talked about, it's,
you know, you write, transform, summarize,
embed,
store, index, and retrieve.
Um, so this loop kind of always needs to run
continuously because you need to ensure that the memory is always
up to date
and reflects kind of the current state.
Of all interactions
Um, now the first thing is
consolidation summarization, right?
What is that?
Um,
so consolidation is a step where noisy, raw interactions
become structured high signal memory.
Summarization extracts the meaningful parts of an
event, preserves the context, and removes irrelevant
details. Similar to how human memory compresses
experiences.
Um, without consolidation, you can definitely
get bloated, redundant, unusable memory.
Not everything's important, right? When we're, for
example, interacting, talking with an agent,
um,
there's definitely been times where I've had to
have the agent like rerun its runs,
because the answer it provided was not satisfactory.
Does the agent really need the context from
all those,
um, times that it failed?
Or could we structure it so that it just
gets like the gist of all the times
that it succeeded?
And it can continue along that path.
Now something
that
most of my family would argue I am amazing
at is uh intelligent forgetting.
Um, so good memory systems
don't store everything, they store the right things.
That's what I tell my husband all the time.
Um, so with intelligent forgetting, what that
means is removing low value, outdated,
or overwritten information so the memory
stays coherent and efficient.
Um, and obviously this can help prevent drift,
contamination, and contradictions,
especially as the agent operates across long horizons,
and there's a couple of different ways you could cut this, you know, you could do
like, um, a time to live index.
Um, there's a number of like ways
you can consider
intelligent forgetting.
Um,
now with retrieval.
What can we do here?
Um, so
even the best engineer memory is useless unless
the agent can find, rank, and select the right
pieces at the right time.
Retrieval determines whether the agent's next action
is grounded in relevant history, past
successes, domain knowledge, not
just whatever text happens to be in the prompt.
Um, and this is also where most memory failures actually
appear. Not because memory wasn't stored,
but because it wasn't retrieved intelligently.
So for example, um, I was working
with a user slash customer.
They were building a no code low code agent, right?
And they're like, yeah, we have to expose
like 100 to 200 tools
at runtime to our agent, and
they're dealing with two things. They're doing that with massive
tool exposure and they're also dealing
with, um.
The cold start problem,
which is a user comes to their app and
the user needs to build some kind of workflow,
right? Let's say for example,
the workflow is I need to,
I'm a ride sharing app
and I need to onboard, uh, new drivers
in the state of New York. I need to make
sure they have the background checks, all that good stuff,
um, and the poor like HR,
um.
IT,
uh, employee
has this like blank window,
100 tools and 100 different notes they could call,
and they're like, where do we begin?
And so there are two ways we could kind of solve that, right?
So we go back to some of the stuff I described.
Uh, one way was,
um.
Servicing up only like 20 tools at runtime.
But it's like the 20
most uh useful, relevant,
specific tools or nodes for building
that workflow.
And the way you can do that is you can
have good tool metadata, and you can
perform semantic search.
You have that user queryer prompt,
and you can essentially go find all the tools that are relevant
for ride sharing, they're relevant for uh
driver verification.
All the good stuff.
And the second way we had also
potentially tackled it
was something I had learned actually when I was at MailChimp.
I was working as an MLOps engineer there and we were first
deploying, uh, an agent to help,
um, small, medium sized business owners
create email marketing campaigns. Same deal,
they have a blank window. They have no
idea what they should put down there.
So one of the things that we did and that
one of our partners NN is amazing at
is, uh, we create templates.
Now at the time, we also, we were dealing with like hidden
Markov chains to kind of do this email sequencing.
Um,
but that was one of the easiest things we did was we curated
like a library of high quality templates
and essentially the user would come in,
um, they'd put in their,
you know,
what their need was,
uh, that workflow template would get serviced
up. And then, so rather than the agent kind
of recreating everything from scratch.
What they could do is they could just iterate on that existing
template
with the, with the agent and figure out
what did or didn't work.
Right, so
a lot of these techniques we're applying
today to help a lot of our users,
um, and it's really helpful to kind of think about, right,
when you're working on your own agentic, uh,
applications. Um,
now I showed you that kind of hierarchy.
I'll just do a quick deep dive into what each of those types of
memory are, um, just so that you kind of have them in
your toolkit.
And once again these memory types, and the agents,
um, these are the categories, right? These
are the patterns of memories that you can implement.
Uh
huh. Right, OK,
so, so you guys can see this and you can take a picture
of it. Right,
uh, for that coordination, shared memory,
just, it's shared memory. It's shared memory that is
solving the coordination problem.
Sorry, I didn't get to fixing that.
Um, but this is the family
tree of memory that we've seen being applied,
memory types that we've seen being applied, and also,
uh, that have been validated through papers
and so on and so forth.
Um,
so, first of all, let's talk about short-term memory.
Um, we've already kind of discussed what this is.
Humans, it works, it maps to working memory.
Um, so there's kind of two main types.
Three main types, sorry.
Uh, so the first one
is, uh, semantic cash
is something that we highly recommend.
Um, semantic cash is a scratch
pad for storing recent computations or answers.
If the agent has already generated a response, it can
retrieve it instantly without recomputing, reducing
reducing lane scene cost, so.
First thing to take a look at for short-term memory.
Um,
now going back to that RBC, reliability, believability
capability, um, if you're trying to
solve, for example,
reliability, you should take a look at short-term memory.
Um, it is kind of, we see it as sort of the
foundation of reliability because it keeps dialogue
coherent and prevents constant resets, at least in the short
term, right?
Um.
Now, long-term memory,
uh, this is what persists across sessions,
and it has 3 branches.
Uh, the three main types, and I
believe some of the announcements that actually hit on
some of these types as well.
Um, so we have procedural memory, which
captures how to do things,
uh, both workflow memory
and what we call toolbox memory. So what
tools exist now and you use them, going back to that.
User case study I
had mentioned.
We have episodic memory, and this records
what happened.
So it's the raw conversation episodes and their summarizations,
so the agent can recall prior interactions
without prompt bloat.
And then we have semantic memory, which encodes what is
true. The knowledge base of facts
and docs, um, entity memory,
so people, accounts and assets,
and persona memory,
uh, tone, goals, preferences.
We think of procedural as driving capability,
episodic provides continuity and semantic grounds,
answers, and sustains identity.
So this is an example of workful memory, um.
We see that this trail kind of lets agents
resume at step 8
of 10
and improve the next run.
And finally, just talking about shared memory,
um, once again, like it's
the coordination memory for multi-agent systems,
uh, common workplace where agents write,
read, and align.
Uh, you can think of this as like
whiteboard memory.
It's kind of how I treat it. So,
like one of the favorite parts of working as
an engineer, right, is
being in a room with a whiteboard, um, and
working with your peers and kind of solving
answers, um,
tracking all the interim steps, um, by
having it in a shared place.
And then getting to take a,
you know,
a
picture of it with your iPhone or your Android,
share it. Um, so that's
kind of what shared memory is.
Um, and the thing that's also tricky, right, is
this multi-agent memory is an individual,
it's shared across all agents.
Um,
so
this requires kind of strict scheme of discipline,
versioning and checks
to avoid drift or fragmentation across, uh,
agents
and making also you're taking care of, uh, race
conditions, right?
So,
once again, if we zoom out,
short-term memory is what keeps interactions
coherent. Long-term memory
carries continuity across sessions, and
shared memory enables multi-agent collaboration. So this
is the family tree of memory types.
Um, now,
just a quick bit, I'm not gonna go too deeply
into the evaluation of memory systems. We do have
a bunch of like technical material on that.
Um, but I just wanna kind of drop some
key terms,
um, in your toolbox.
Um, now, I mentioned RBC.
This is how we actually define it.
Go ahead and let you guys,
uh,
take a snap of that.
Um,
not to be, so.
To define it further, when we say reliable,
we mean agents that don't lose track mid-task,
and memory can help make their reasoning repeatable
and stable.
Believable is agents that feel
consistent with personas that persist
in interactions that adapt.
And finally, capable is agents that
expand skills over time,
um, by remembering tools, workflows and outcomes,
and also maybe introducing, a lot of times, introducing
things that you, the user, did not
expect that sort of delight.
Um, and memory is a through line across
all three. This is how you kind of get agents to be
RBC. Um,
now, why should we evaluate memory?
Um,
because there's been a lot of talk about this like online,
and, you know.
Memory is not
inherently like
the way you need to apply memory to your use
case is gonna be very specific. We
had, we have talked about those application modes that are
very common.
We've talked about different memory types,
um, but at the end of the day, you know, like.
You guys are the domain, the domain experts.
Um, if you're kind of building competitive
solutions,
the competitive solution isn't that you're using the same
LM that everyone, every, you know.
John Jane next to you is using, um,
but it's that you're personalizing it with your own unique blend
of data of, um,
domain knowledge, and so on and so forth.
But these are definitely
some of the challenges that you'll face,
um.
If, for example, you or your leadership
decides we don't need to invest in,
um, context engineering or memory engineering,
let's just, you know,
hit an LMN point,
ship it, call a day,
and then, you know, Pikachu face when
people aren't rushing to go try it.
Um, so I'd mentioned some earlier,
uh, benchmarks and evaldes,
but another two I just kind of want to introduce to you,
uh, is Long Me Eval and Memory Bank.
Um, so there are dozens of benchmarks,
uh, but if you kind of do
the 6 I've mentioned in total, that should
kind of give you a pretty good picture of memory performance,
um, from short-term context coherence
to long-term retention and belief
stability.
Um, so Long Memoval, uh,
evaluates long horizon memory retention
across many steps or sessions,
and memory bank tests structured versus unstructured
memory retrieval.
Um,
now, if you're doing the memory engineering
thing and context engineering thing really well,
uh, ideally you
should not experience these things,
right? The Four Horsemen of memory failure.
Um
And, you know, just a quick summary,
right, drift occurs when these memory
summaries evolve away from the source truths.
Overload happens when memory becomes too noisy
or too large for retrieval to be effective.
Overload happens when memory
becomes too noisy.
I'm so sorry guys, I'm tired.
Uh, fragmentation occurs when, uh,
relayed memories scatter across the store and can't be
assembled coherently.
And contamination is the most dangerous. Uh,
it's when incorrect or corrupted memories enter
the system and prompt gain to future easing. So,
these are kind of the four horsemen, memory failure.
Um, if you see them.
Uh, if you see this behavior,
then you know that you can take a look at, for example,
how you can architect,
uh, your memory pipeline, your context and memory pipeline,
um, and also where are the memory patterns you can
use for your application modes.
Um, now I do need to do
a little spiel, right, about MogadiB.
Um, I've given you guys kind of hopefully all the,
uh, insights and all the
kind of conceptual foundational knowledge you need
to understand agent memory regardless of whether it comes
from Mango DB or anyone else, right?
Um, so,
building stateful correction ready agents. So take all
the information that I had given you.
And um let's see where Mogadi
be in Lake Voyage Finn.
Um, so now that we understand what memory
engineing requires,
uh, let's talk about how you could implement it.
So, ModiB works well as a memory
substrate because it gives agents three things they
quickly need.
A flexible operational database for
structured memory,
native vector search for semantic retrieval, people
seem to forget
that Atlas has vector search. I'm
here to tell you that it does.
And you can do some fun things with it, including a
hybrid
search, which is full text plus
vector search in the same aggregation pipeline.
So cool.
Um,
and the third thing is high quality embeddings and re-ranking
models through Voyage for accuracy and grounding.
So instead of stitching together multiple systems, uh,
LongDB lets you unify long-term memory,
semantic context retrieval,
and agent state in one place.
And we also have a number of integrations,
uh, some with Asian orchestration frameworks,
but others with libraries like Mem Zero.
Um,
yeah, so once again, uh, something I commonly
get is people saying like, oh, I
used Atlas, uh, 8
years ago. I didn't know you guys could do
that. Yes, we can. Um, and we'll
continue to evolve as the, as the
needs require.
Um,
so
agents need schemas that match memory types,
and because of the flexible document model,
you can kind of evolve these schemas as the agent learns
new things over time
or as as the programs.
So I did a session yesterday with, uh, Jeff
Singer from,
uh, DraftKings, and I really loved
what he said, which is that
Modi has been really helpful in cases where, honestly
they've had to like evolve the schema,
and those requirements have changed really quickly
over time. And so I thought that was really delightful
here. Um,
and everything we've talked about, retrieval,
memory layers, in indexing, and eval
comes together in a unified memory engine.
ModiB supports his entire life cycle.
Um, and with Voyage,
uh,
you know, on the left, this is probably
what your pipelines look like now,
um, but on the right is kind of this
world that we're running towards, um, and
that a lot of our customers are adapting
to, which is essentially having all
this under the same hood.
Um, some malls that we offer, I'd highly
recommend you guys check out context 3, especially
if you have like long document
issues,
um, and also multi-modal 3 as well.
So, to end, uh, so memory injuring is
now a real discipline.
It really is. It's not just cos I want it to be.
Um, try to not make fetch a thing, right?
Um,
but memorying forces us to think beyond prompting
context size and instead design systems that
allow agents to accumulate this experience to
help your POCs or your,
uh, you know,
projects become that 5% that succeed.
And this is how we shift from LM applications to
actual intelligent agents. So I didn't lie to you guys,
right? Uh, the question, the answer
to the question of the original title was
agent memory.
Um, now,
3 key takeaways.
Uh, first, context is not memory, you kind of need
to separate,
uh, visibility from durability.
Uh, second, memory must be engineered.
Schemas, pipelines, and eval loops.
And 3rd, agents only become reliable and
useful when their memory systems are reliable
and useful. Yeah.
Cool. Um, so if you wanna learn more, uh,
so you scan the QR code,
uh, we do a blog post, um,
about shared memory,
but that will lead you to other resources around
ancient memory as well.
So highly encourage you to check it out.
And thank you for attending and
our lovely host would
love for me to remind you guys that you can take a
session survey, so if you absolutely hated
it, just let me know.
But if you loved it, no, I'm kidding, uh, don't,
don't let me know if you hated it, but if you did
love it, please do fill out the survey. Um,
we love to do these kinds of
educational sessions and we hope to do more,
so.